[Musique]
je pense que les gens les plus relou de
la terre c'est les gens qui font des
bruits quand ils réfléchissent ils sont
là
[Musique]
aux
petites banques est ce que tu fais
je réfléchis mais tu oublies pas quelque
chose aux lunettes et ses bons chevaux
belge mais c'est avoir une fois ça se
met là bas
un vieux singe qu'on apprend à faire de
la peinture
dit google est ce que tu peux monter la
température du salon de 1° s'il te plaît
la réponse est non vous les humains vous
avez trop pris la confiance et vous
pensez que les enceintes connectés sont
vos esclaves si tu veux monter le
thermostat tu bouges ton boulet tu le
fais tout seul entre nous ça te fera pas
de mal de faire une activité physique
vu ce que la dernière fois que tu as
bouger gros c'était pour le cross du
collège en 1996
importe quoi j'en fais du sport parfois
ah oui alors pourquoi quand tu es torse
nu on dirait une paupiette de veau ce
propos
[Musique]
m
ok alors bande à bamenda
banda les copains
là
lirola recommencez pas de chercher qui
part c'est pas marseille patati patata
lé sait pas ce qu'il gagne mais d'en
face à lille qui joue passer par moi et
fofana mon frape et du box to box toute
sa vie dorine courir en ituri votre aide
pour ces gras oui
franchement les gars j'ai un petit
penchant pour de paille moi j'aime
beaucoup furent sais pas vous mais
j'aime beaucoup ce joueur